- [Voiceover] Hey,
grammarians, so we've already
talked about the idea of the comparative
modifiers, right, so you
know the difference between
saying something is cute
and then saying that
something is cuter than
that thing, and then
looking at, like, I don't know,
let's say we're looking at
a puppy or a mushroom, a little mushroom
with a smiley face and you'd say,
"Oh, that's the world's cutest mushroom."
Right, that's the comparative,
we've already covered that.
I would like to talk
about something I think is
a really interesting topic.
"What's that," you say?
A really interesting topic.
Now, what's that really doing there
in this little phrase?
A really interesting topic.
Well, it's modifying interesting.
We recognize that this
is an adverb, right?
Really is modifying interesting,
which is an adjective.
Interesting, in turn, is modifying topic.
But, the question is,
what does really mean?
What is it's function?
And the answer is that it's a type of word
we call an intensifier.
So the function of really
is to just double down
on the idea of interesting.
So it's not just an interesting topic,
it's a really interesting topic.
You could also say it's
a very interesting topic.
Or even, an extremely interesting topic.
And that kind of gets us
into this other category
which is called adverbs of degree.
So an intensifier, let me
just step back a little bit,
an intensifier is a type of adverb that
modifies an adjective or
another adverb in a way
that doubles down on the
modified thing's meaning.
So it's not just an interesting topic,
it's a really interesting topic,
so it's like extra special,
extra interesting.
It makes, it intensifies,
it really accentuates
or makes clear the fact
that you're trying to
drive home the
interesting-ness of this topic.
But frankly talking about
how interesting a topic is
is a pretty good shortcut for boring,
so in order to talk
about adverbs of degree
I'm going to talk instead about the
Incredibly Deadly Viper,
which is a creature from
A Series of Unfortunate
Events by Lemony Snicket,
so the Incredibly Deadly
Viper.
There it is, there's your
terrifying, horned viper, yonder.
And what the word incredibly is doing here
is, it is serving as
an intensifier, right.
But it is also what we like
to call an adverb of degree
because it's saying the extent to which
this viper is so very deadly.
However, if this viper had a cousin
that was the somewhat deadly viper,
maybe we can blunt its teeth somewhat,
maybe it's got square teeth.
That's the somewhat deadly viper.
We can see that somewhat, this word here
is changing the meaning of the phrase.
It's not just the deadly viper,
it's the somewhat deadly viper.
It's import has been blunted
slightly as have its teeth.
And you could also say, what if he didn't
have any teeth at all, this
ostensibly deadly viper?
What if he just had little gums?
Well then he's the barely deadly viper,
instead.
And these words like
incredibly and somewhat
and barely, these are adverbs of degree,
so they illustrate the degree to which
the viper is deadly dangerous.
So that's basically what intensifiers
and adverbs of degree do.
So, whenever you think of an intensifier
just think of the word very,
and when you're trying to figure out
what an adverb of degree is, well that
kind of answers the question, how much?
So if you want to double down on the
meaning of something
you use an intensifier
like very or extremely, and if you want to
express a degree of something
you could say, let's say we're
talking about a cup of tea
or something and you want
to express how warm it is.
You could say it's too hot.
You could say it's slightly hot.
You could say somewhat,
or almost hot.
There are a lot of
different adverbs of degree.
But that's basically the distinction.
An intensifier is powerful but
it has a very narrow usage.
And adverbs of degree, you can use for
a wide range of uses to express
a variety of different meanings.
That's intensifiers and adverbs of degree.
You can learn anything.
David out.